this creepy crawler sports a fiery red  pigment throughout its body and it's got  a temperament to match  [Music]  the fire lake tarantula's body is a  brownish black color with a rich red hue  along its legs  this spider is a mid-sized new world  tarantula growing around five to six  inches  this particular species is easily  provoked when surrounded by other  animals when feeling threatened they  flick off what are known as urticating  hairs which cause irritation and a  burning sensation to predators  native to mexico the fire lake tarantula  prefers dry scrub land they are  terrestrial species often found in  burrows self-made or abandoned by  rodents and lizards  the illegal pet trade combined with  ongoing destruction of natural habitat  causes considerable concern for the  future of this species this is the  mexican fire lake tarantula  [Music]